So next up we'll add some flip-flop node functionality.
So unlike a gate function this allows you to only cycle through two options.
Whenever there's an input execution on this left hand side it'll fire out A and then it'll
fire out B and then it'll return to A so it'll go A B A B every time it's entered.
So there's some more documentation on flow control if you'd like to follow up but let's
go ahead and add some flip-flop functionality into our project.
To start thinking about how we will use a flip-flop we need a way to have multiple inputs instead
of a single begin play.
So we'll replace begin play with a keyboard input instead.
I'll right click and for this I'll just use a hash key because it's easy to find.
You can add any keyboard event you want.
It's sometimes hard if you wanted like the C key for example you'd have to scroll through
all these to find an input called C but a quick way as well is if you right click hit
hash key and add a keyboard element hash you can also click this button here and then say
C from there and it'll override to C.
So that's just a quick way I always just right click add a hash key and then change it to
whatever I want because it's the quickest way to get there.
So completely up to you what workflow you use I'm just going to delete C and keep my
hash key.
I'm going to move the hash key to the left a bit.
If you have these around I'm just going to select them and delete and next I want to
add a flip-flop.
So I'm going to drag off pressed and type flip and then you'll see a flip-flop so I'm
going to hit enter with it selected there at the bottom.
So we've got a flip-flop we'll go from A into the first view target and we'll go B
into the second view target.
Now we can change the blend times if we want or the blend exponents they will edit the
blend time so you'll transition from one camera to another instead of snap.
For this example I'm just going to keep the snap functionality though.
So I'm going to copy which is ctrl C and ctrl V for paste.
I'm going to drag the controller into the target here.
I'm going to go from B into the execution input.
I'll drag the controller somewhere which is a little easier to see and just so we keep
things nice and organized.
Now the next thing I will do is add another camera reference actor.
So you can right click and duplicate.
I like to just create a new variable and call it camera ref 2.
I'm going to give it a category and you want to make sure that the variable type is that
cine camera again.
Again I'm going to use a soft reference.
The reason why I don't duplicate and I instead opt to create a new variable.
I've just found in the past if I duplicate some variables with soft references and when
we package them into projects I just end up with some bugs sometime in the referenced
variables here.
So not quite sure what workflow that is but I always just create a new one.
You'll see that it's not got camera ref 2 there.
So I'm just going to jump back in.
I'll expose that property then compile and save.
Now the last thing we want to do is add well I guess before that we need to add our camera
reference.
I've just noticed that so I'm going to hold ctrl and mouse drag.
The reason why I hold ctrl is just if I just left mouse drag it says get offset.
If I hold ctrl and drag it it'll get it and if I hold alt and drag it'll set.
So that's like a nice little tool tip.
You just want to make sure that's resolved again.
So drag off there hit resolve.
Go to new target.
Now by default actors don't consume input so you won't be able to press this button
by default.
If I compile and save and I go into my map and I hit alt and p to play and I hit the
hash key I can see nothing is happening.
Now the benefit over a level blueprint is if I and this is again just found by going
to the level blueprint.
If I added an input here that would work perfectly fine.
And so if you want some kind of user input the level blueprint can sometimes be the
easiest approach.
But because I want to keep this contained within this blueprint what I'm going to do
is I'm going to right click add another begin play event.
I shouldn't say another.
You can only have one begin play event but because in a blueprint sorry but because I
deleted it previously for the hash key I can now use it for something else.
I'll get a reference to the player controller.
So I'll just control C and control V.
I could have dragged a wire up there but it's just going to get turned into spaghetti.
And then on the player controller I just want to enable input.
Now this is a little bit of a hacky solution.
I'll just hold down control and move that input to player controller.
Just to make sure.
There we go.
So I've dragged that.
I've got a wire going into player controller.
Compile and save.
And it is a hacky solution.
For these kind of projects it's fine because you're not going to be relying on any kind
of game architecture.
But in a video game for example you wouldn't want to do this.
This just would override it in ways that wouldn't be reliable when moved into the code.
So we just want to test this now.
So I'm just going to make sure you compiled and save.
I'm going to jump into my map.
I'm going to hit alt and P or you can press the play button at the top.
I like alt and P just gives a quick shortcut.
And now what I want to do is I want to press hash on the keyboard.
And so we have got functionality.
The main remaining thing to do now is just add a second camera.
So I'm going to select my camera that I have.
I'm going to hold down alt and drag.
I'm going to right click.
I'm going to pilot it.
I'll just put it into a new location.
Maybe this is extreme close up.
I'm going to eject.
Maybe I'll call this close up bushes now.
Again the naming for this specific project isn't necessary but just to keep things organized.
It's good to just organize as you go.
I'll set my dinosaur head.
I'll go to my camera ref 2.
I will assign the camera ref 2.
And let's hit escape just because I don't like having things selected whilst in editor.
I'm going to hit alt and P to play.
I'm going to hit the hash key.
And there we go.
And if I hit hash again it snaps to the second camera.
And the great thing now about the floor control is if I hit hash again
so it keeps flip flopping and flip flopping.
So a bit of bonus for you now.
Not mandatory but in case you didn't have anything working for example
we can go into the camera switch.
I can drag and drop the window down into some different real estate.
I go back into my map and depending on where you've got your window
you might be able to see this drop down.
Or if it's a smaller window you can just go to the arrow keys
and make sure that this down here.
I'll just try and select it.
The property at the bottom says BP camera switch.
Again just dragging it out here.
The real estate of my screen isn't allowing that interaction
but if I just drag it out here I want to make sure BP camera switch is selected
which the debug object is in this dinosaur head.
This is called BP camera switch and debug is on BP camera switch.
Now what I can do is I can zoom out and just again I'm just trying to
fight with the real estate of my window here but I care about this section here.
So you'll see now when I jump in I can debug this and show that the inputs are firing.
So if I hit Alt and P now if I press hash you'll see that first line
firing out to the set view target in the bottom of my screen here.
Second line is flowing out to the B and so we keep going A B A B A B.
So we can see that control working and it's also just a nice way to introduce
debugging into your scenes if something isn't working.